et on connaît un été exceptionnellement
chaud avec des périodes de canicule vous
savez c'est un impact pour nos
agriculteurs et là-dessus faut rajouter
aussi d'autres la pandémie nous allons
parler avec marcel groleau qui est
président de l'union des producteurs
agricoles bonjour monsieur gros lot oui
bonjour
première question comment ça va dans les
champs cette année ben c'est comme vous
le dites là c'est très sec on on a
manqué d'eau en mai et en juin puis
ondulé même des périodes de canicule a
aussitôt que juin alors c'est ce que
cette année les récoltes sauf que ça
varie un peu d'une région à l'autre
aussi mais principalement là à ce moment
et si ce qu'on peut mesurer c'est la
rareté au niveau du foin du forage je
prenais levage des animaux on verra les
conséquences plus tard de cette
sécheresse là où de ces périodes de
sécheresse lol lorsqu on commencera la
récolte des grès un peu plus tard la
halle amigou et cet automne alors mais
c'est un été extra mois de mémoire le
gecko chez nous en aux pauvres
ah oui vous avez de mémoire vous
rappelez pas d'avoir eu un étudiant
tchèque
non la deuxième coupe on off commencé la
semaine dernière chez nous puis j'ai
jamais vu une situation comme celle là
alors soucier localiser le jeu vous
parle d'une situation localisé dans une
municipalité de ted friedman dans la
région chez nous c'est très très sec
le foin est très rare depuis les
producteurs sont inquiets aussi on
manque d'eau plusieurs producteurs donc
s'approvisionne à partir de sources ou
de puits artésiens les nappes
phréatiques ont baissé donc en manque
d'eau objet de transporter de l'eau pour
abreuver les troupeaux sont une autre
situation qui est très difficile pour
les producteurs qui vive
ouais parce que les puits sont les puits
sont à sec puis aussi l'association du
foin ça n'impacte toute l'année ça le
point c'est difficile à trouver lorsque
c'est sec
c'est naturellement tout le monde en
manque puis c'est coûteux à transporter
parce que ses volumineux même si c'est
pas et c'est pesant alors c'est c'est
très coûteux a transporté donc le faudra
on a mis des cellules de crise en place
dans les différentes régions du québec
on essaie de voir vous y aurez
des foins avant mais à des coûts
raisonnables pour le transport c'est ce
qu'on est en train de faire actuellement
aussi ce que j'aimerais dire aux
producteurs c'est de calculer les coûts
que vont représenter que représente la
sécheresse qu'ils vivent actuellement au
niveau du transport de l'eau et et
autres là on va en refaire le cumul de
ces couleurs pu voir de quelle façon
pourra les aider à mesure que la saison
va avancer
peut-être aussi avoir une aide
gouvernementale pilon le succès il c'est
ça ou c'est aussi donc monsieur gros
loup et des variations de températures
sont de plus en plus important est de
plus en plus fréquents est-ce que vous
vous sentez là sur le terrain que les
agriculteurs sont mieux outillés
bon déjà on a commencé à voir des
changements dans par exemple au niveau
de l'élevage la ventilation des
bâtiments a beaucoup progressé ces
dernières années
justement pour faire face à cette
période de canicule aussi ceux qui font
qu'ils pratiquent le pâturage on a
aménagé des amoureux des déciles
d'abreuvement des animaux à l'extérieur
parce que là au niveau du ministère de
l'environnement ne peut plus non plus
abreuver les animaux dans des cours
d'eau donc on a installé des sites pour
l'abreuvement au niveau des plantes
qu'on cultive aussi on voit une certaine
progression vers des plantes résistantes
à la sécheresse
donc c'est des choses qui sont des
adaptations qu'on est en train de femmes
et cette année naturellement avec ce
qu'on connaît ces adaptations note jean
paul suffisante
manifestement alors vous faudra
continuer de progresser
voir comment on peut mieux s'adapter à
ces périodes de chaleur et à la
sécheresse maintenant faut ajouter la
pandémie on parle de plus en plus qui ne
manque de main d'oeuvre dans les chalets
la piste sans lui ça vous a fait mal
oui on a eu de la difficulté à recruter
des travailleurs le gouvernement a mis
en place des programmes pour inciter les
gens à les travailler sur les faire mais
bon autant au niveau des étudiants qui
avaient qui avait l'habitude de
travailler sur les fermes où elle ou ou
d'attirer de nouveaux travailleurs sur
nos champs dans nos champs c'est sûr que
la pcu était un frein alors mais en même
temps on comprend que lis-je ces mesures
n'a été nécessaire pour ce qu'elle est
vraiment
pas de revenu également mais ç'a eu
l'effet que vous expliquez que au niveau
du recrutement
alors puis on manque encore deux mille
travailleurs étrangers qui normalement
aurait dû arriver dans les dernières
semaines ou dans les prochaines semaines
et là avec la situation de la pandémie
au guatemala et au mexique
ces travailleurs là on aura de la
difficulté à les halles et à les amener
ici au canada donc c'est une situation
qui est assez qui est très difficile
cette année puis on voit déjà que ça se
reflète sur le prix des aliments de
genève est mentionné au début de la
pandémie qui aurait un effet sur le prix
des aliments
indéniablement plus on voit cet effet de
ce produit alors quel endroit on voit un
effet plus important sur les neiges ce
sur les fruits et légumes d'abord le
qu'on a constatée par ce qui est sûr les
coûts de distribution des aliments sur
les mesures qu'on a dû mettre en place
pour se protéger des travailleurs tout
ça induit des coûts de production une
augmentation dans les coûts de
production qui se reflète maintenant un
peu sur le prix des aliments afssa selon
moi ça va se poursuivre cet automne
alors on espère que la situation va se
sa sa grave repas davantage
naturellement mais c'est une 7e c'est
net c'est un été et une année de melgven
qui s'entraident 6,7 pour les
agriculteurs bon on leur souhaite bonne
chance aux agriculteurs avons marre
merci beaucoup et un marcel groleau
d'avoir été vus tous merci beaucoup au
revoir nez